Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P I recently did a segment on the
Pacman Finance Channel recommending what I believe
to be ten or so personal finance books that if
everyone read, you would be ahead of 98% of the
population in terms of personal finance knowledge.
I did that segment last week. Someone wrote in I'm
sorry, they called in and they said, David, what
about Rich Dad? Poor dad. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: David, it's Alan from Jersey. I'm
watching your video on the tax
and finance channel about, yes,
finance books. You suggested in your list do not
include Rich Dad, Poor Dad by Robert Kiyosaki. I
can't believe you left this one out. I know it's
one of the best finance books that teaches you
the difference between thinking like a rich
person versus thinking like a poor person.
For example, poor person works hard, pays
their taxes and gets screwed over when
their company lays them off. But a rich person
like Kiyosaki writes a scam book is Rich Dad,
poor Dad scam book. Then he gets in bed with
Amway, which is a scam multilevel marketing
thing. Yes. And forces and ways people
buy his book. And that's part of his whole
scheme that made him the self-help guru. So, yes.
Speaker 1: Robert Kiyosaki, his main strategy for
getting rich is to write books and sell them to
people, telling them it's going to tell them how
to get rich. So if you can emulate that, that is
that is a way. Now, listen, I read Robert Kiyosaki
is Rich dad, poor dad, like the first couple of
books when I was probably 16 or 17 years old.
And I don't find them substantive and I don't
find them serious. Now, whether he is a, quote,
scammer or not, I will leave that to the critics
to decide. But if you say to me, David, sir,
I need recommendations for personal finance
books that are really personal finance books,
not Kiyosaki telling me to get get just get start
getting real estate that will generate passive
income and then buy more of my books and maybe do
some Amway stuff. Now, if you want my actual list
of good finance book recommendations. Go to David
Pakman dot com slash recommendations. And then
we also have the finance content at youtube.com
slash Pacman finance. I do not recommend Robert
Kawasaki's books or his courses or his whatever
it is that he is selling. The books I recommend
are cheap, they are complete and that they
aren't going to try to sell you more stuff.
And again, if you read these ten or so books
that I recommend to you, your personal finance
knowledge will be greater than that of 98% of the
adult population. I've got nothing to sell you.
They're not my books. They're other people's
books. YouTube.com slash Pacman, finance and
David Pakman dot com slash recommendations on
today's bonus show. The FDA wants to simplify
the use in the updating of COVID vaccines. What
do they want to do? And who is already flipping
out about it? I think you can probably guess. The
first artificial intelligence powered robot lawyer
is going to represent a defendant in court next
month. This is super interesting and we're going
to discuss it at length on the bonus show. And
lastly, the woke mob. Oh, wait, no. It's the right
wing mob. The right wing mob has indefinitely
paused their Eminem spokes candies over right
wing pressure. I thought we were the people who
canceled. But they are doing a lot of canceling.
Sign up. Join Pacman dot com. You'll get instant
access to the bounce show. I will see that.